and tonight joe biden has completely and
totally frankly just humiliated the
united states on the world stage any
confidence the world had in our country
um is now gone saigon circa 1975
steroids former defense secretary and
cia director leon panetta rightly
calling it yeah biden's bay of pigs and
thanks to the ill-fated actions of our
derelict low-functioning president if
you want to even say that that's
somewhat charitable the absolute worst
case scenario has been playing out
before our eyes biden ignoring the
advice and the counsel of his top u.s
military commanders they wanted the slow
evacuation of u.s troops based on
conditions on the ground he ignored the
warnings from our intel on the ground
and now afghanistan has fallen to the
islamic extremists the taliban in record
time kabul oh they just said last week
oh it'll be 90 days their earliest that
they'll ever take over kabul it was
overrun in a matter of hours taliban
fighters they are now in control of a
massive stockpile guess what of joe
biden u.s taxpayer paid for weapons ammo
vehicles other supplies abandoned during
biden's hasty retreat he wasn't even
smart enough to take our munitions out
terrorists from al qaeda and isis they
were freed from multiple prisons all
across this country they soon will be
plotting and planning their future
terrorist attacks on all of the u.s and
the rest of the world fomenting terror
the american flag lowered over our
embassy beyond humiliating as diplomats
hastily were evacuated by helicopter to
the airport the very thing biden said
wouldn't happen this view of warning
what you're about to see is incredibly
graphic but take a look at this horrific
video earlier today thousands of
desperate afghan citizens fleeing
certain death at the hands of the
taliban now rushing to the tarmac of the
airport trying to cling to a departing
c-17 military plane some crushed under
the wheels planes and others fell from
the plane midair you know during its
ascent hoping they might be able to hang
on and get out of there
dozens of others desperately attempting
to board any and all commercial planes
parked on the runway at least seven
people died in the chaos and tonight as
we speak there are approximately ten
thousand americans that are still at
kabul's international airport
desperately attempting to flee the
country
joe what are you doing
6 000 u.s soldiers now are in the
process of re-entering afghanistan taken
over by the taliban to try to now secure
the airport to try and save americans
without a doubt a complete total failure
of leadership planning and execution and
true to form as the disaster unfolded
over the weekend joe biden was nowhere
to be found aside from this bizarre
photo showing joe all alone at camp
david crouching over an empty table
during a zoom call and we got nothing
from biden all weekend while this was
unfolding in real time his press
secretary wasn't available to circle
back on anything jen saki she was on
vacation if you wrote her you got an
auto reply from her email account
reading i will be out of the office from
august 15 to august the 22nd hope you're
having a great vacation the vice
president kamala harris was also m.i.a
but today well finally joe biden comes
out of hiding for a very brief scripted
speech by his staff before headed back
to vacation where he blamed everyone for
this catastrophe but himself but says
the buck stops with him but i blame him
him him and him take a look
when i came into office
i inherited a deal that president trump
negotiated with the taliban
the choice i had to make
as your president
was either to follow through on that
agreement
or be prepared to go back to fighting
the taliban so what's happened
afghanistan political leaders gave up
and fled the country
the afghan military collapsed
sometime without
trying to fight
i know there are concerns about why we
did not begin evacuating
afghans civilians sooner
part of the answer
that some of the afghans did not want to
leave earlier
i am president of the united states of
america
and the buck stops with me
but i blame everybody else and by the
way did he have any problem overturning
uh let's see president trump's secure
border wall stay in mexico did he stop
building the wall
trump that stopped catch and release now
is joe biden's process and release
in the middle of a pandemic without
vaccine passports vaccine mandates mass
mandates and just send people all over
the country uh same with energy
independence yeah he took us away from
that too has no problem changing
policies on everything to recap biden
blamed the afghan people the afghan
military the afghan president the afghan
government and president trump when all
else fails because laughably claiming
that the buck stops with him
pretty spineless and pretty cowardly and
of course biden took zero questions
following those remarks i'm sure he was
too exhausted too much work it's been a
whole 20 minutes and immediately
returned to his vacation at camp david
for more r r
and uh ice cream with sprinkles on it
but let's be honest this speech would
not have happened today if not for the
immense blowback from pretty much anyone
with half a brain even joe's protectors
and the media mob could not ignore the
full disaster that this is take a look
how
does the biden administration
miscalculate
this intelligence so gravely this is a
fiasco this is uh you know a big part of
life is execution or implementation and
this is just malpractice this has just
been a fiasco by any and every measure
this is not just about the overall idea
of leaving afghanistan this is about
leaving hastily and ineptly secretary
blinken how did president biden get this
so wrong but joe biden is going to be
the face of the failure of the
withdrawal
friends and foes alike are calling this
withdrawal
a fiasco a debacle and it is one that
apparently the administration did not
fully appreciate or see coming there's
no question the white house was wrong
about the length of time they had wrong
about the strength of the afghan
military
wrong about the reach of the taliban in
so many ways this is completely on
president biden and
to sum up joe biden did everything wrong
remember just one month ago biden was
assuring us that a taliban takeover was
not inevitable at all because they had
such a strong army and they had an air
force and everything and there was 300
000 well trained some of the best
trained soldiers in the entire world and
only 75 000 taliban uh no that's not
going to happen under no we won't have
to be you know taking people out in
helicopters at the last minute we won't
have people racing out of there wrong
again
is the taliban takeover of afghanistan
now inevitable no
it is not why
because you have the afghan troops have
300 000
well-equipped as well as equipped as any
army in the world and an air force
against something like 75 000 taliban
it is not inevitable there's going to be
no circumstance where you see people
being lifted off the roof
of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan
three hundred thousand well-equipped and
they have an air force i mean as good as
any military on the face of the earth
the exact opposite happened joe these
are the images of people being lifted
off the roof of our embassy over the
weekend when you said it wouldn't happen
yeah you're saigon your bay of pigs and
it gets worse
in june biden's secretary of state this
guy's a total idiot tony blinken the guy
that sucked up to china and took
lectures on human rights from them as
the chinese are now threatening our
military bases day in and day out they
don't say a word well he proclaimed that
a quick taliban takeover was not
possible
yes it was don't we know that now
one we're not withdrawing we're staying
the embassy's staying our programs are
staying and uh whatever happens in
afghanistan if there is a significant
deterioration uh in security um that
could well happen we've discussed this
uh before
i don't think it's going to be something
that happens from a friday to a monday
so i wouldn't um necessarily equate the
departure of our forces
in july august or by early september
with some kind of immediate
deterioration
number one you lied number two people
will die number three you arm the
taliban and you need to be fired number
four again the exact opposite happened
now many are calling biden's ill-planned
retreat worse than saigon the biden
administration is actually begging the
taliban please terrorists please please
allow americans to safely leave the
country
two decades after 9 11. make no mistake
this is about so much more than just
afghanistan
the world is watching our allies and
enemies alike they are witnessing joe
biden's pathetic weakness on the world
stage it is humiliating and embarrassing
for this country now one of china's top
newspapers they're predicting that
america will abandon taiwan just like
they did afghanistan and now openly
planning a total reunification let me
interpret that for you joe that means a
takeover of taiwan and meanwhile russia
doesn't fear us either with all their
cyber attacks they don't respect us as
well and they're now supplying all the
energy for all our western european
allies because you let it happen and you
granted him a waiver while
simultaneously firing american keystone
xl pipeline uh workers great job joe and
after joe gifted them with the new
pipeline well the u.s has now endured a
never-ending stream of russian cyber
attacks the uh in iran we have the
mueller's now continuing to enrich
uranium at an accelerated pace uh and of
course joe had the south koreans give
iran seven billion dollars even after
joe attempted to bribe them with more
international currency in afghanistan we
now have al qaeda's safe haven is back
biden's steadily destroying america's
standing on the world stage and now
americans everywhere are left safe and
less secure as they plot plan and scheme
their next 9 11 attack on america in his
book obama's secretary of defense robert
gates wrote that biden had been wrong on
nearly every single major foreign policy
and national security issue over the
past four decades remember he didn't
want to take out bin laden and according
to politico biden's former boss
president obama even expressed a similar
level of concern telling a fellow
democrat quote don't underestimate joe's
ability to bleep things up this is the
difference by the way between joe biden
and donald trump for all the snowflakes
out there that got so oh they got the
vapors every time donald trump set out a
mean tweet and everything well they
feared trump the world feared trump when
donald trump gave a threat they believed
him biden they know is weak and not
running the show the world sees it
they're not influenced by america's
media mob and propaganda outlets america
and the world deserves better the world
needs a strong america sadly under our
biden i fear this is only the beginning
and it's only going to get worse